what do you think people love that look
I have a daughter I pray that a guy like
this walks through my door some day he
says mr. Harrison I'd like to date your
daughter Lee God oh you gotta take a
parents will love Ben he's so nice but
itched in our memory the not-so-nice
bachelors here are Chris's top
cringe-worthy moments well I mean it's
called a mesnick's it's called a
mesnick's for a reason so that's got to
be number one right his crotch that's
just the beginning
quick recap Jason picked Melissa Rycroft
but then during the after the final rose
show dumped her and picked Molly who Mia
still married to I knew that Jason and
Melissa had broken up essentially so mad
at you but then I also knew he wanted to
have a chance to at least talk to Molly
so we thought why not sit them down and
let them speak are you still in love
with Molly yeah I'm so disgusted with
you the Jake Vienna breakup it just
exploded stop interrupting me some word
got out that Jake had looked violent or
made a fist so we said well now we have
to air it because everybody is gonna
talk about this and thinks we're hiding
something it was very raw like a lot a
lot Scotty went from one published
season yeah well I mean he gave him a
lot of reasons to but don't expect Ben
to make this list he was such a pleasure
to be around to work with for the entire
crew in diamond in the rough